Speaker 1: We haven't even had time for these
clips this week because it's been so busy.
Donald trump jr suffered a complete and total
meltdown over the fbi search warrant that was
served at mar a lago. There are actually
dozens of clips of don jr that have floated
around over the last week, but i'm going
to look at one specific clip with you.
This one is of junior sped up, as he always is.
And the hypothesis has been this guy is on uppers
and whether he is or isn't. Drug addiction is
not funny. That's we're talking about a disease.
But even for his own standards, he is particularly
hopped up and incoherent during this viral video,
which got a million and a half views. See if you
can follow any of what he's even saying here.
Speaker 2: My father says that he would have given
them what they wanted had they done this. But no,
they needed the FBI hostage rescue team, the HRT,
their elite tactical unit, and 30 something agents
to show up to my father's home where they then
wouldn't allow or didn't want any lawyers present.
Speaker 1: If you're not watching,
the facial expressions are bizarre.
The hand motions are frenetic.
Speaker 2: Because I'm sure
given all of the examples of totally aboveboard
stuff that the FBI done, that's totally great.
Like, I don't know if I'm the FBI. You want
someone's lawyer there so that there can be
no other claims later on. But, you know, honestly,
they don't care at this point, like given all of
the things that they seem to have fabricated or
lied about and all of these things. Guess what,
folks? There's exactly zero equal justice under
the law. You know what? Pro tip for life. This
is an ultimate life. I become a Democrat. Then you
can do whatever you want with no accountability.
Speaker 1: This guy is out of his mind.
Speaker 2: No legal action. They'll just
leave you alone. Okay. But you needed the HRT
to exercise this warrant at Mar a Lago. Give
me a break. All right. Again, Hillary
completes 30,000 emails until you and.
Speaker 1: I actually don't know at this point
when they say bleaching emails. This all started
because Trump seemed to think that, Oh, I don't
even know if I can explain. Trump seemed to think
that there was a there's a software called
I believe the software is called Acid Wash.
And Trump at one point genuinely believed
that Hillary Clinton was acid washing hard
drives like you would do to a pair of jeans,
like it was popular in the late eighties,
early nineties, acid washing, and now it's
grown to where they talk about bleaching emails.
They haven't said they've oxy cleaned
them, but that would be the next thing.
I genuinely can't tell what they believe
about whether literal bleach is being used.
Speaker 2: Primers to bone. Nothing
shady about this folks, but severing
phones. That's just the best ever imagined.
Speaker 1: Bill opens the door to the basement
and Hillary is in there with a mallet.
Speaker 2: Just destroying phones,
cooperating, and they still have to show up
this way. You know why? Because they're there
to intimidate you. They're acting like
the fascists. We've been seeing them be.
Speaker 1: And of course,
the fascism is on the rise.
Speaker 2: Last few years, though, and for all the
Democrats talk about Republicans being fascists,
these are the guys acting like it. Give me a
break. Okay. They wouldn't look at Hunter and
deals in China or Ukraine or links to Russian
oligarchs with links to Putin or links to human
trafficking. And literally videotape evidence
of him saying that the Russian mob may have his
laptop there. That was Russian disinformation.
But we need the HRT team to go tomorrow,
Lago. It's intimidation, folks. And the number
one thing we can do to save America and prevent
us from becoming the dictatorship that
these guys would like is to drain the
swamp and fire all of the bureaucrats.
Speaker 1: Imagine thinking after
everything that's happened over the last six
years at this point. That Trump is the person
who's going to be draining the swamp. You
would have to be in a fantasy world to be
able to believe that. So there is the latest from
JR, another one of these hopped up bizarre rants
and it didn't look too much better for
Eric Trump, which we will talk about next.